you got John Rambo coming in on this
mission to rescue these American PS who
are you know probably listed as Mia
there's no evidence at all that there
were any Americans still held after the
war none my name is Bill Allison I'm
professor of history at Georgia Southern
University I've been a battlefield tour
guide in Vietnam and I've written
several books on the Vietnam War
including one on Mei today we'll be
looking at some Vietnam War movies and
judge how real they
arege below we're going to go down and
check it out all that's pretty accurate
the helicopters themselves or the uh1
Hues as well as the helicopter in the
scene the smaller helicopter that's a
Loach so Vietnam is quite rightly known
as the helicopter War helicopters were
used throughout the entire conflict
that's actually Filipino Pilots uh they
they borrowed those helicopters from the
Filipino Army to use for this
[Music]
scene now you might wonder why they're
attacking this Village uh it's
supposedly a VC stronghold VC the
Vietcong why do they have to get it over
this Village into into the river why
can't they just go up the coast if
you've not seen the film there's a river
Patrol boat they need to get on the Nung
River problem there is the tital flow is
not deep enough for the boat to actually
get across the sandb bars and that
actually is real that's a
problem playing Valkyries just kind of
blew your mind right is that real uh
probably less so in at least one case I
know uh Winston groom a veteran who who
did scops he remembered uh flying around
at night playing Vietnamese funeral
music to try to freak out the VC was it
effective I would think not and I think
part of that is making an assumption
about the Vietnamese that they're not as
smart that they would be fallible to
Superstition and things like
that okay there's Napal at work Napal is
ubiquitous in the Vietnam War it's very
common it actually is derived from World
War II give you a point of comparison
probably about 30,000 tons of Napal was
used in Korea almost 400,000 tons of
Napal was dropped in Vietnam so it's
highly flammable it's kind of like a
gelatinous substance so if it gets on
you and burning it sticks to you you
know most people don't survive it but
it's designed to destroy cover and if
enemy are in there then from from your
perspective of using it all the better
which is pretty horrific it's a horrific
weapon I love the smell of napom in the
morning napom does smell obviously with
everything that's in it it's going to
have a very gasolin petroleum like smell
so it has a very distinct odor to it for
sure now there's Robert dval as Colonel
Kilgore probably one of the most iconic
characters in any Vietnam film he is
based on a guy nam in part by a guy
named John Stockton who was the
commander of the unit that's depicted
here the ninth Cave of the first Cavalry
division as far as it being a piece of
film I'd give it a 10 right in reality H
you know it's a little ludicrous on a
lot of levels so I'm guessing probably
about a
five the pavin also known as the NVA the
North Vietnamese Army so it's the
People's Army of Vietnam the pavin
getting ready I think that's pretty
accurate what this scene is depicting is
a January 1st 1968 attack on fire
support base Bert which is near the
Cambodian border it's part of the 25th
Infantry division's area of operations
Oliver Stone the director of platoon was
in the 25th Infantry Division and was
involved in these engagements so that
weapon they put in the in lodged in the
tree there it's in essence a marker for
the VC and paven guys to know where
they're at so if they have to go back
they'll see that marker in the tree
they'll have a way
point
this is a an outer defensive perimeter
and they've got trip wires set up for
flares to go out and that tells you
somebody's out
there
there okay what Charlie Sheen just did
there was fire the the Claymores so
you've got these Claymore mines wired
out along the perimeter so when the
enemy comes through they're explosive
and they shoot out a bunch of shrapnel
it's a clicker uh and so you try to bang
it so that it it will it will it will
fire so the bunkers that you see Charley
Sheen in and others if you had the time
to cut down a couple of trees and put
some logs on top of you that's a good
defensive position to be
in you had a command bunker which the
guy runs into with a grenade blows it up
right I'm like good luck with that one
you got to know where it's at two you
got to be able to see it it's dark
except for the the flashing of different
explosions and stuff which means you're
going to have trouble maintaining your
night vision so uh that probably more
likely could have been hit by mortars or
you know something like that from the
enemy D everything you've got left on my
P we are coming
for okay this is a really desperate act
to call everything remaining every
everything up in the air the the problem
with that is you're going to kill a lot
of your own guys and how often that
happened in Vietnam very rarely so a
fire support base is actually it's it's
a small post but it's very well
organized very well defended what's
depicted here is not that and so uh the
VC are hitting it before it's well
defended and the actual battle I'm not
sure that's actually you know that
realistic if you watch the scene in its
totality
uh you know I'd have to give it a six
maybe um as far as the actual real
battle I think it's a little
overplayed tunnels were kind of the
go-to fortification especially for the
Vietcong but for the pavin that part I I
don't know I I I could see where they
would have entrenched
bunkers probably but to spend the time
to dig an entire complex like was
depicted in the scene seems to me a bit
of a stretch VC would do that because
the VC usually are locally based not
moving around as much they have an
operating area and they're going out
pavin they're they're moving
around so this is where uh we're we're
really infatuated with the helicopter as
a way to bring lots of troops into an
area that otherwise you can't really get
to and the idea is an element of
surprise although a bunch of helicopters
coming at you isn't really surprising
because you can hear them from a long
way off so this is depicting the
November 1965 Battle of the yading
valley this is really the first time
where American forces face off against
the People's Army of Vietnam the pavin
like you know inh T AET right this is
part of americanizing the war
that you know the Johnson Administration
the Pentagon MCV military assistance
command Vietnam determined that the
Arvin the army of the Republic of
Vietnam is not quite ready to fight on
its
own this is a pavin operation those were
clearly Viet Kong they had the Hat you
know the conical hat the the black
[Music]
right
okay so the way the pavin reacts you
know it it seems like there's just Mass
wave assault and that's actually kind of
accurate the Battle of deian Fu in 1954
against the French uh general xap you
know just ordered wave after wave of
these costly assaults I mean they they
won the battle they defeated the French
but at Great cost and was criticized
for this but this kind of stays in the
doctrine if you will uh for the pavin of
this is how you do things and in this
scene part of the tactic is is to get as
close to the Americans or to the to your
enemy as possible so if you can get
close and hug your enemy as quick as
possible that makes it much more
difficult to to call in the air strikes
but they're learning this is early you
got you're talking 1965 here so they're
I don't think the pavin is fully
appreciative of the capability of
American power how quickly it can
respond Broken Arrow Broken Arrow
at okay Broken Arrow for a lot of us if
we heard Broken Arrow we would say well
how more lost a nuclear weapon what's
going on there because that's what the
code word is for a some incident with a
nuclear weapon Broken Arrow may have
been the code word for that particular
operation if they were in danger of
being overrun what happens when you call
Broken Arrow all Air Assets in the area
whatever is up there is supposed to
converge on your position and drop on
the coordinates that you give and that's
what happens here uh and that's real but
it's not how more going Broken Arrow
Broken Arrow according to the book it
was the uh forward error controller
minor inaccuracy but Mel Gibson has to
be the hero
right so there's napom and in one of
these attacks it is true that the napom
was dropped so close to Mo's perimeter
that a couple of American soldiers were
actually burned in the napom attack and
killed I know a lot of people who really
like this film and and because it's
dramatic and and if they've read the
book especially but this it
just it fails on a lot of levels I think
I'd give it a
five got can you see them they got
rifles can you see the
rifles this this is a bad situation
we've totally lost command and control
here he didn't want them to fire but
someone started firing the lieutenant
there he's clearly lost it cuz he's
seeing things that aren't there so he's
seeing VC running around and he can see
their sks's or AK-47s Tom Cruz's
character is looking and going I don't
really see that you've got bad
leadership at the top uh who makes a guy
makes a bad assumption then you have
lack of command and control discipline
over your own troops this is not outside
the realm of
possibility this did
we oh my God Jesus Christ this just
shows how things can go wrong and a lot
of civilans get hurt and killed so if
this Village had been a VC stronghold
and there had been actual Viet Kong in
there clearly identifiable and
everything no doubt they would have
fired into the village and then swept
into the village this is not so much
like a search and destroy mission it's
more of a sweep and clear Search and
Destroy which is a pretty common tactic
in the in for the Americans in the
Vietnam war is basically go out try to
find the enemy make contact with the
Enemy then call in Firepower to to
destroy them literally kill them but
when you do things like this in the
scene and you kill a bunch of Innocents
that sets you back a lot with the local
population but there were instances
where villages were attacked uh
innocently so for example the Meli
Massacre which occurred in March of
1968 uh when a company of American
troops as part of task force Barker went
into the sunme Village complex and in
specifically mili itself expecting to
find an entire Battalion of Kong and
they get in there and there's
no 48th local Force Battalion it's not
there the villagers are there but
they're so amped up that they just some
immediately assume that they're all VC
by the end of the day between Mei and a
couple of other places in that area uh
well over 500 men women and children
were killed but mili is a rarity it's an
exception I I'd give it an eight it
shows just how a couple of bad Visions
or happen stance can can cause a tragedy
in in a in in war and and unfortunately
war is all about tragedies
[Music]
happening so the setup here is you got
John Rambo coming in on this mission to
rescue these American PS who are you
know probably listed as Mia the war is
over and and there's still Americans
being held by the nasty Viet Vietnamese
right there's no evidence at all that
there were any Americans still held
after the war none but after the war
there became a cottage industry in
Vietnam and especially in Thailand of
selling false information to families
who had people listed as missing and all
those missing names are listed in the
New York Times They know who they are
they know the units and everything they
can create fake dog tags and rust them
up and everything and you'll pay you
know $10,000 to some body in Bangkok who
has his information on your loved one
right in the hope of Ross perau got hung
up in this trying to rescue people again
Chuck Norris made six
films about going back and rescuing
these people we get our history from
movies so we all come to believe that
this is the case right it's a tragic
deal all the way all the way around I
[Music]
think when this film comes out you know
hi to the Cold War you got to have the
Russians in there right now what a
Russian been out there at this prison
probably not thousands of Russian and
Chinese technical advisers military
advisers were in North Vietnam
throughout the whole conflict a lot of
them were there to train for example
North Vietnamese anti-aircraft Crews to
to operate these Soviet and Chinese you
know fairly sophisticated anti-aircraft
weapons but they also have uh you know
operational and strategic advisors so
that's not uncommon at all I got to like
a who's muscled like that and can
operate an m660 with with impunity and
kill pretty much everyone around him but
as far as reality goes zilch got to give
it a
[Applause]
zero okay let's set up this scene this
is from the Green Beret it was filmed in
6667 released in June of 1968 so this is
after the Ted offensive after the new
Hampshire primary after you know Martin
Luther King's been assassinated
Johnson's announced he's not going to
run again this is not the best time to
release a go ra Vietnam film this is
based on Robin Moore's novel on called
The Green Berets in this particular
scene this Green Beret team is going to
kidnap this
pavin Colonel or general but as far as
units working together like with the
Green Berets you know maybe 1965 6667
there's probably more the Americans
working on their own there would always
be an Arvin liaison with bigger units
like probably at the Battalion or you
know regimental level certainly at the
division
[Music]
level the game must have been engrossing
because they don't hear anybody else
you've got six or seven guys coming
through with combat gear and combat
boots on on a p and beam wood floor that
apparently doesn't squeak and they're
none the wiser it's just totally
ludicrous and now we have to do this in
dramatic fashion and we have to repel
off the second story because apparently
the guys playing Maan still are not
alerted that something's going
[Music]
on ah everything goes according to plan
so the trip wire uh is that a common
thing for for Special Forces to do I'd
say no because you want to be able to
get out of there and get away quickly if
you're on some sort of mission anywhere
close to like this one but even then do
you have time to do it that's more of a
thing you set for a defensive position
can I have a rating of should never have
been filmed in the first place zero
totally and I hate to do that because
part of me likes some John Wayne films
but this one h no
this scene is depicting the battle for
ha city which is part of the Great Ted
offensive in January 1968 what you just
saw with the tank going forward the
Marines going behind the tank yeah
that's good policy but then you see all
the firing so it's been pre-sighted but
what's funny to me is then the Marines
get up and immediately go into that area
where they just pre-sighted pre ranged
fired so if I was the bad guy the enemy
I would have fired again while the
Marines were all right there but they
don't do
that now to be clear this looks nothing
like whe City at all was City there's no
tall buildings like that it's it's very
dense buildings there's not a lot of
maneuver room but here it looks really
open in part this is because they film
this outside of London at beckon Gas
Works the one thing they do get right
because it's outside of London it's
overcast so during the battle for Wade
it was overcast for most of the time
which made it difficult to get air
support
in now if you notice at the very
beginning there when the firing starts
to come from the building it's not a
single sniper it's several machine gun
set up there a sniper would have fired a
couple of shots and got the heck out of
there these guys are in place so it's
hard for them to move so that's why the
Marines respond which is blasting the
area with fire trying to hit
them all right so there he is taking a
picture it was not uncommon for uh
soldiers to have nice cameras because
they get RNR sometimes they can go to
Saigon or hoian city I should say now
they're officers they can go to Hong
Kong or someplace like that and and you
could buy really nice cameras for not
very
much and this would have been a pavin
sniper the paven snipers are going to go
out to specific targets VC snipers
tended to use the tactic just as to
cause chaos and fear so you randomly hit
somebody you see a guy on a radio
headset talking on the radio that's
probably an officer you're an easy
target the visual part of it the what
the setting of it is is to me all wrong
other than the overcast Skies that is
realistic I don't know I'd give it
probably a
six I don't think he needs binoculars to
see that the enemy is approaching but
it's a good touch the scene is really
about the 1972 attack on Quang tree so
the pavin have occupied Quang Tree City
and the Citadel and the Arvin are trying
to take it
back and the Arvin of course they've got
all the American stuff so their uniforms
were American styled that's spoton so
you got to remember this is 19 you know
72 following the Easter offensive so by
that stage even though the United States
is technically still in the war we're
not doing a lot of combat activity at
that point most of our troops are out of
Vietnam by
then
equipment's good they've got
AK-47s some RPGs there so the pavin unit
that's depicted here is is is a basic
infantry unit yes by this time in 72
they've got tanks they're a conventional
Force the only thing they don't really
have a lot of is air uh you did see
initially uh the uh Ford artillery guy
calling in the artillery strikes which
didn't do anything but there's no
depiction of him you know asking for an
adjustment of fire to hit which I think
in reality there would have been a fire
adjustment and they would have kept
firing on those apcs until they got
really close to the paven perimeter
there so that part of it I think is is
not accurate I like this movie uh it's
its production value is not great um but
the storyline and this the period it's
set in and and the way they depict
soldiers and everything I like it and
this battle scene even though the Arvin
guys are out there exposed and whatnot I
got to give it a six or seven actually I
kind of like this one so I have two
favorite Vietnam films one is from the
early 70s called go tell the Spartans
and it's early in the war it's in the
advisory phase and it's kind of
foreshadowing the problems that were
going to arise
the other one I like a lot is actually
good morning Vietnam hey thanks so much
for watching I enjoyed it I hope you
enjoyed it if you want to watch some
more click on the next
[Music]
video